But I have an incredible respect for
the workload here, so you
always think politics is a bit of
chili vanilla, but that's real. I
work more than in a startup. I can
really say, yes, so you sometimes have
night negotiations until 4 a.m., for
example  I negotiated the heating law,
I do business and
construction, living and then we still
continue at 7 a.m. so no one asks
when we meet and if you
have a hard night at the startup, so
at kitchen stys we don't have it at 7
o'clock started again the next day
Welcome to the OMR podcast for the
second time as a guest but this time in a
completely different role
I'm still happy to talk again about
similar topics and completely different topics
She definitely has a journey behind her She is an outlier in the
German start-up scene  because she's
now really relevant, I have to
say, I've become a politician, I'm quite a
buff, we're sitting together here in her
office in the German Bundestag,
welcome Verena huberena, hello Philip, it's
nice that you're here. We
met for the first time in 2018, yes, you were
still there  Founder exactly or entrepreneur
actually both exactly 5 years ago
now not everyone
who listens here will remember that's why
you're from Tria plays
a role because that's where you also
have your constituency then you studied business administration at
the WU so at the  one or one of the
top schools in Germany and then
founded straight out of my studies
and then sold quickly so the
company was called Kitchen Stories,
a cooking app can say exactly, it is
still being continued great
and is now even more
than a cooking app everywhere  where there is
content, there is now even
the second cookbook, there is a
website and also 60
employees in the team and I
then left that to run for the Bundestag,
yes and the two of you did it back
then with mtingau, that was yours
Co-founder was exactly right and
I think she also had venture capital. Yes, we
had botstrapped at the beginning because with
girls and the kochapp,
nobody wanted to invest and we got
started like that and then
included angel funding after Lounge and that
was also Verena Pauster  whose paths
still cross with us here now
and then venture capital so
we had Cherry Ventures with us
point9 Sunstone which is now called
Hardcore I think and then in 20117 the exit to
Boss Siemens Hausgeräte and exactly B
bought Haus you were on board for a while  and
then at some point you get out of there and the
question has to come up, you will have been
asked about it from time to time,
you can also read it,
the B sword is said to have been between 25 and 30 million.
Unfortunately, I'm
not allowed to talk about it, but
You can read a little bit about something speculative dimension
that is normally speculated on, no, it
was speculated on and is
n't really crazy now, maybe
not, no, okay, okay, so at least
you can think about it. They will then
probably be founded by two
investors in it, maybe there will be  A
third have heard that means that you
already have a lot of money and you also do it
yourself in addition to your job or have been making
investments for a long time, no,
not anymore, that was also very important to me,
that I said all or
not at all, so I am  Then I went
out to Kitchen Stories, so to speak, also for the
election campaign as managing director.
As the founder of Kitchen Stories, I
had another two or three angel tickets, but I
think: A I don't have the time B
it's not that much money and C I do
n't want to make myself vulnerable either
Assuming I'm now investing in
some fintech and taking care of it
afterwards,
I'm saying I don't have any
new projects and I'm taking care of other
tasks in this country. Let's just
briefly say that it sounds so
simple, based on my studies
and how long it took  D years just
not that long no so I'm
out for 2 it's been 7 years exactly but
the exit was exactly okay so still
relatively linear also somehow the
development with wiec and it's a
little bit lucky you were in the
early mobile phase no, that was one of
the first cooking apps that was just
a bit probably timing luck
jaid so I think it was timing luck
in the sense that you had the old players
so the kruna and yess with chef but
also those who tried frantically
Developing an app
was able to overtake the iPhone because the
iPad was relatively new on the market
23 and the content was
digitized very quickly and of course we were
on the market quickly, but
content is also extremely difficult to
monetize, so we have it
too  worked with B2B
advertising partnerships and as
you also say from the outside,
entrepreneurship always sounds
super easy, super linear when it worked out, but I
always say it was the best and
worst time of my life, so we
somehow shot 100 videos
in the holiday home at the beginning and  I
washed up until four o'clock at night, where did that
actually come from? That's an
interesting story. I was never good at
cooking and my co-founder
always watched YouTube videos and I
said, man, I need
the videos you watch because then
I can  Maybe it also said
yes, but on YouTube I don't cook with
stop and play. We somehow need
step pictures. We somehow need
a shopping list. A timer  In the
end it
became such a strong product that
Apple CEO Tim Cook came to Berlin in a very prominent way
and then came to your office and
basically ennobled you. Man,
we need apps like that, that was great because with
them we have pancakes  made and
in fact that's the Apple
story that they want. Somehow
an underdog comes along who has no money, who
somehow has passion and desire and
then they do it better than those with
huge amounts of millions who,
in theory, can do something like that very easily
I mean everyone makes
recipes dr Öger television station publishers
we've already mentioned the
household appliance industry but
really implement it in such a way that there is still
room for a better product that
you couldn't imagine at the beginning
okay so that, so to speak,
can set an example for the whole business
You can also listen to it again from the
podcast back then. Now I've noticed that
we've seen each other from time to time over the years.
You were also at the
festival. I think we saw each other once
at a festival in Berlin.
You were also surrounded by
I observed CEOs and politicians like
suddenly we couldn't
speak much and now I also
notice that you speak completely differently than
you did back then
I'm also trying, and I really take that
to heart, not to end up in such an
awkward politician's existence
because at the end of the day
people elect people and
somehow authenticity and the way you
want to be and what you want to say
you can't  always say everything but
of course it's a bit
different when you speak in the German
Bundestag than when you
speak in front of your company or at a
startup pitch event because you speak
on the one hand for the people
sitting there  uh, your colleagues
who are not always experts in the field,
so when we discuss about us,
the
agricultural colleagues also sit there and then
you also speak for the people up
in the stands, the spectators and the
people on Phöniix Instagram or
others  Channels and
then always have to think about
how do I formulate it now and who am
I speaking for and what point do I want to
make with all the points that
can be made? So communication is
of course the tool of
politicians and that's perhaps why it has
now  with a few yes appointments,
appearances and what do I know, I was then
led to a different conversation
than as a greeter, but I've also gotten
older, maybe in 5 years you'll get older,
don't look at it, but
thank you, then tell me how it went for
you  Politics
started earlier, I think, and then always
with the SPD. Yes, that's also
very important to me. So many people say, hey, you're a
founder, an entrepreneur, why are
n't you in the FDP? Then I always say,
first of all, I'm for the SPD
decided I wasn't a founder,
I wasn't a business owner and I have
n't become a different person now when did
you join the party 201 okay
so it seems like it was during my
studies or something like that
because I worked at Burger King in Tria at
the main train station  and there was
no minimum wage and in 2009 there was a
federal election when Frank Walter
Steinmeier was the candidate for chancellor for the
SPD and was now federal president and he
said why don't we actually have a
minimum wage in Germany and he gave
a fiery
speech for the minimum wage in front of the portanikra in tria  and
I was totally carried away by it and I
asked myself, right, I get
€6.13 here and now I've
got a raise to €6.18 and
a minimum wage would be something for
me but also Oleg next to me at the
checkout somehow  Wife and children have to
get away with it, we all know that
the SPD didn't win,
Merkel Westerwelle did, so it was
black and yellow and
they tackled one thing directly and that
was the Mövenpick hotelier
tax relief, so a privilege
for the hotel industry and then  I
said, man, there are a few more
problems in the country, namely for the people
who work and then I joined the SPD. I
also come from an SPD-
dominated household. My father is a
locksmith, my mother
studied theology, you could also assume that
not only looks at itself but a
little bit around it and that's why the
SPD's values ​​and what
characterizes it have always suited me well,
but were your parents already
active? No, not at all. I
now have two of four, so two
of three from mine  I also got my family into the SPD, my
brother
and my mother are now SPD
members, my father, I still work
but no, my family was never political,
so political in the sense of Pol, you
became political in Burger King, yes from
Burger King to the Bundestag
wrote my local newspaper okay and
then first of all you
just stepped in and didn't
do anything and then you did so if you did then so um
but first of all
everyone who wants to get involved politically
you don't have to, that's
often the wrong impression when I do  If you
join a party, you won't be
arrested and you have to
be there somewhere every Tuesday. It's also good to take part and
pay contributions because that's what
party work depends on, but you can also
go to the local club and I
first went to the SPD tria center and
then actually did it there  Participated in Tria
Suburb but now the
big problem is politics. Whenever you
move, you actually start from
scratch again, which means I'm from Tria
to whou after falling there and then
to Berlin and at the beginning of the
founding time when you're at 6 p.m  You
'd have to go to the local club but you'd have to work until 4 a.m.
That doesn't work, so that
means I only went to the local club again in Berlin
when it got a bit quieter
at Kitchen Stories,
okay and what
do you do in the local club so you are  So
street election campaigning then sort of
stands and what you know or
the nice thing about the local association is
that all kinds of people come together in a people's party,
so it did me a lot of good when
I was in Berlin, everything is so very
startup, bubble-like, no  Everyone asks and
how much money have you collected, how is it
going, but in the local association you meet
once and there is the pensioner,
the car mechanic, the teacher and the
student and you meet at the
local association meeting and then there is
usually a current topic and then
you also talk about federal politics  but
then it's very specific about local issues,
where do you want to have a bicycle street,
what's happening right now, for example, the
green spaces, how many local associations are there
in Berlin, wow, that's a very good
question, so we're talking about 30, 40 pieces or yes, yes,
easy, so there you have it  You are
how many people are in the
club? Well, the problem is
that only 10% of the people go to the local club,
if at all. So you have large
local clubs that have 200,300 members.
You also have small ones where 30,40 people
are involved, but  There are usually
10 to 15 people coming and I was even on the
board of the SPD Alexanderplatz
aha yes and then you
sold the startup at some point then you got
out of there and then you
probably already thought about what
I wanted next  do with my life
and nothing like that, so it was such a
bite,
um, I noticed that I do
n't just change the world in the local association, so you
write motions for the
party conference, you get involved, but my
laws Federal policy is also made in the
Bundestag  and the SPD was going through
a very difficult phase before the federal election,
we were somehow
at 13% and I was very worried about
how long the
SPD might last and then
a door opened that doesn't open too often
and that is  that
a candidacy for the Bundestag became available in my home country
because Katharina Balele, who
is now Vice President in the European Parliament,
was the Trier MP,
who was also Justice Minister,
Family Minister, so she
went to Brussels, so to speak, which
means that in Trier they were
looking for a new successor and because of that  But things
were going so badly in the party and we had
just elected the party chairmanship in a, I
would say, open casting, members
said, man,
we're going to do a completely new
procedure and then I was at a
summer festival here in Rhine-Palatinate in the
The state representative spoke to the
members of the state parliament from my
constituency and somehow
realized that yes, man, if that
is the possibility right now then you should
think about whether you should
go to the BT now and give it a try or whether
you will know in 10 years  not when there
's someone new again, where are we
now is the time now we're working on
the wheels for the future and then
I said completely or not at all I'm
applying aha that's Heß they
asked themselves a bit too much and ne
asked that you will  you don't have to, so a
lot of people have
also said that it's actually impossible
to be set up if you have
n't already
networked and worked on site for 10 years, so to speak,
and how did you
manage it because they did this
had a process and said you can
apply and four
applied and you really had to
fill out an application form and go
through several rounds so I was
basically convinced by what
motivated me to take part aha yes and in the
end I said um  The local association
decided to take you because there
are two of them, that's not
easy either, so the city council and then the
district around it and they
then spoke out in favor of me and that's
how it was at the end of your speech and
D impressed the people there too  and yours
your background probably too and
exactly that but I also had to
clear up a few prejudices because they
thought so, now here comes
the arrogant entrepreneur in one piece
from Berlin and now because she
's bored she wants to do that and
somehow too  say hey, I'm
interested in making a difference for my homeland, I'm interested in
us really now,
if the future isn't waiting for us,
how do we shape it, not
just those who already have a lot
get even more and get to know each other there
and also  really so heartfelt and not the
cliché that you have to
work at the base, so to speak, for over 20 years or 10 years, that's
not entirely true because you've
already worked at the base
and you've been in the base but
then not at all  so intensely and for so
long and it still worked out that you
now how are you 35 today, I'm still the same, so
to speak, so our youth organization
is valid until you're 35 years old, yes, so we
arrived here in Berlin relatively quickly, so to speak, and that's
really a great achievement from
Lars too  klingeball who, as general secretary,
really strategically ensured
that young people also had the courage
to run for office, that the
state associations also had the courage to
put people forward and, to be
honest, many people also said,
man, things are so bad for the SPD
back there  You do
n't necessarily need to run on the list, so that,
for example, from our group,
more than half of all SPD members in the Bundestag are new because we
performed so well and because
a certain generational change
has now taken place, but that
means  Your constituency was previously
won by Ms. Bale.
No, it was always CDU for 19 years and
you won for the first time in 19
years for the SPD, yes, okay, but would you have
been moved here if you weren't?
I had a good list
position on the list  Number 6, but you never know,
well, if things are
going really badly now, it might
not work, you only had the security
because you won the constituency,
really okay, and
I didn't have the security when I
went out because I could have  Yes, it ca
n't be set up either, so I
also said to Kitchen Stories that
I don't want to say that if it works,
I'm gone and if it doesn't work, I'm
here because I think about it, I
'm exactly where I want to be and
I can  I give you 120%, that is, you
gave your own fmer notice, so
when you were already at BOS and then you said, I'll
try it now. I got
hooked somehow at the summer festival.
Yes, I also had
coaching with mengting because that  It's not something
where you're giving notice of termination from Telekom,
so your
heart is hanging on, and of course it's
also attached to something you're building up, but when
you have two hearts in your chest
that are beating and you're experiencing it, or
have you already experienced it back then  A
lot can really change in politics,
yes, back then, even more so now, yes,
okay, then let's just say before we
get to today, you have to
win this election campaign first, so
what was the hack to do that,
so it was easy  a Soz say new
fresh person what's the point if you
're honest what I don't know so
I really
gave myself full time for 9 months to work there
I knocked on 10,000 doors I
also did everything countercyclically
differently really  Since nobody can do me,
so I had to make sure
that people knew me, in the
shortest possible time, that means
door-to-door campaigning, of course, where you
have a face, that's something.
Secondly, you have to act countercyclically, so you
always see before the elections 6  Weeks 7
weeks in advance, the posters are up. I
made the first wave of posters late earlier by doing one with
Olaf Scholz and Malu Treier in town hall
and I just put
up posters. Oh, we were allowed to do that
because an event is also allowed to
put up posters ah  Then, Hack, you've
already entered the startup list, then of course
also digital marketing, so we've
posted videos and advertisements on both Facebook and Instagram, but also actually
glossy banner ads on resttinentaren
like Bild.de because if you don't
happen to be on Facebook now  You
also have to reach the people and in the classic way
I sent everyone in my constituency a
letter because I said hey
here I am, I want to listen first
and then you could answer questions and
you also introduced yourself, so to speak,
before this hot
election campaign phase  was but was that was that
the advantage that you sousage now
really or were at all an alien so
as if yes I don't know is it common
to be a woman there too to be young
I can't even imagine or it's
common that you come from the digital world
No, well, you have many, many attributes
that, imagine to me, are different than
others, yes, and that also caught a lot of people
because often this prejudice
is yes,
why are you now in politics to
drink coffee and I was able to say to Hal,
hey, I founded a company
I left that behind in order to
make a difference here for my homeland and
this pitch on the door at the
end of the day then I
held a wooden spoon in my hand and it said
Verena Hubert's time for a
change on it, so a spatula and
That's a must, you have exactly
because people don't feel like having a
big discussion when you ring the bell. How
many bells
did you ring?  I saw that in I
think in the Obama election campaign it was
also explained how we did it. We
looked closely at
which streets were
realistic and then exactly which ones
were left, so to speak, so that we
thought very carefully about where
the 10,000 were  We also have an app from
the party from Will Brandhaus
where you can look at exactly this data
because they always say
strengthen strengthen so you do
n't go to the most conservative village because
if you ring the bell then you're more likely to go
Competition is more motivating,
but you first have to mobilize
where you have potential but people
might not vote and then
say hey, that's me, it's really important
that you vote because that's
more of a quick win than
trying to convince someone who is
not the SPD WT okay okay that means say
a few more hacks so
the intense sound is not a hack
just core work there yes that's
a bit like starting a business you
have to stick with it you have to
convince people of your ideas
those who don't know you, how many votes did
you need? In the end it was around
55,000, so that's actually if you
made 10,000 calls,
then you've got 20%, so to
speak, if they all
thought it was good  55,000 in the bag, yes,
but you have to say again the
election campaign was under Corona, which means we
couldn't, there was no carnival, there were no
wine festivals, so the moments where you
normally get a lot of people quickly did
n't exist and that's why
it was all the more important that you stop there  You
strategically knocked on a lot of doors in the summer
and you shouldn't
forget that in rural areas it's
not Hamburg or Berlin Mitte,
the neighbor tells the neighbor
that it was there, so this mouth to mouth
is scary or the others don't do that,
but I do too  I was then
convinced in the sense that with the
wooden spoon, the spatula, yes, or
maybe they found me quite
interesting and I also had
a flyer in my hand and you could find out
something about me and what were
your two cores, um  So concerns
theses that you give to people,
so to speak, so you have to sort of internally
set up what did you have as a topic,
um, what people then also
from W who then used you for connection,
yes I have already said
I have myself  always incredibly
excited about politics, I thought it was
slow, it was very tough, we are in a
country where we are somehow suffocated in bureaucracy,
we now have to somehow
move forward quickly and somehow
use the opportunities that we have
through digitalization and secondly, of course
a local issue we
are very poorly connected here we
would need an ICE inrier like that again
but most of them that's the
interesting thing when you ring the doorbell
you're usually cooking,
watching TV or doing sports so either
it went over very quickly
a topic where they say, man, I've
always had the problem
So it
's quite interesting that you have
Instagram and things like that play a
role. I also
started making a video diary during the election campaign
because I said once a
week, Verena's week, I don't want to be
over at the end of the day
I also want to report the results and I want to
take people with me because
a lot of dissatisfaction with politics comes from the fact that people
no longer identify with what is
actually being done, which
you often hear up there
behind the decision
which platform are you on
Instagram Facebook and Instagram
but I also have a newsletter where we also
try very strategically
to collect subscribers and then um well you
really have to have the 360° mix print is
actually a very very
important medium for  me because the
older people are just not in the
digital and there is both the
Trierischer Volksfreund but also the
so-called official gazettes where the
announcements from the town halls
are printed and you can also
put your announcements and invitations in there as normal, okay and one  own magazine
or something like that, no, the
Malu 3ier had the Malu magazine,
we actually thought about it too,
but then I decided on the letter
and for capacity reasons
then focused on flyers and not even
completely but back in the election campaign you had everything
a team alone, no, I had a really
great team on the one hand,
my current office manager Stefan, who I
also know from WHU, who so to speak
quit his job to
take part in the election campaign and
then we had a team of
volunteers from the party  Place in
two constellations such a core team
then a larger team around it
my parents also
helped out really well so our garage was the
flyer packing station and now of course I have
a full-time team through my
work in the Bundestag but that means at the
time this this team at the time was
the of  the SPD financed it or you didn't,
it's actually voluntary work, so you
were
able to finance it a little bit from
yours, so that was very, very
important to me to say completely
or not at all, I mean, through the
founding I was now  In the
privileged situation that I was
able to say, man, now I'm going to put
a little something in here and
now we'll buy the pens and
the flower seeds and
to pay for your election campaign and of course that's
exactly what we'll have
Correspondingly, let's say that you
have to invest in order to
run an election campaign like this, then it
even works. The good thing is that in Germany
you don't have to, so in America you do
n't feel like you need to start with less than 5 million,
but in Germany it's
not your wallet that decides whether you
get elected  od but still have 50,000 €
invested, yes you can also read it in the
annual report 21 you can
look closely there are 100,000 € in it the
party donations from me in the year 21 were
and of course very outliers
but I just said man if
we put this here now
Do it beforehand and then go full throttle
okay hot for a few months then HFT has
of course probably that you
have a few other means to
win this constituency again in such a long time or
of course it always helps but if you now
I'll say one  You ca
n't market a bad product well either, so I
think it was also the combination
of the fact that I
was also convincing as a person with what I
had to offer and not just how
many advertisements do you now see from me
and
your head?  been okay,
I'm going into politics now for 4
years or is it somehow for
longer or did you think that was a
decision I'm really trying
to change the world now I've
actually taken care of it now it's my
new life or is it just like that  You'll
do it for four years now and see how
it goes or so I'm
not worried, but I'll say, um, I
'll do it as long as I
enjoy it and as long as
I have the feeling that I can make a difference
and that's what I want to do
maintain the freedom to question this regularly, as with kitchen stories,
and at the
moment I can say that even though people
often get annoyed here, I think that's the case
in every profession, it's an
incredible privilege to be able to
work here now and that's why
I want to  In any case,
I want to run again, so if I'm set up,
it's not God given,
but I do believe that I
have the trust locally
to win the constituency again and then
here in the next four years
For years, there are
people who have been doing it for
20 or 30 years, yes, that's
interesting, because we have now
honored people for 25 years of
Bundestag membership. I mean, I
don't want to rule it out now, if
you ask me in year 26  still
here but no idea nobody has
the crystal ball but I have an
incredible respect for the
workload here so you always think
politics is a bit of chili
vanilla but that's real I work
more than in a startup I can really say
yes you do  Sometimes you have
night negotiations until 4 a.m.
For example, I negotiated with the Unlaw,
I do business and
construction, living and then it continues at
7 a.m. Nobody asks
when we meet and if you
have a hard night in the startup  So
with Kitchen Stories we didn't
start at 7 a.m. again the next
day and who explained it to you like
the whole game here there is no onboarding
so that's also the interesting thing that's
why I think I can draw a lot
from the founding period because as
The founder doesn't take you in her
hand and say yes, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it,
here
are your appointments or want to follow
committees somehow so Sunday is the
federal election then on Monday
everyone actually comes together in Berlin then
there's already something from them  Group an
onboarding then somehow you get
a package in your hand and then it says
okay here you somehow
first get your ID card that and that's available
at billing points etc pp so let's
say this operational is already taking
place but how does it actually
work?  You negotiate laws
and co. You then learn by
doing when the time comes and that
's interesting, yes, okay, okay, what are
you going to say? The biggest thing you've
done so far, now in the last few years it's been
almost three years, but
I would
say the biggest thing  I contributed to the fact that when
the war broke out here, we were
already able to achieve stabilization in the country
because I helped negotiate the gas
and electricity price caps and
not only negotiated them, but at the beginning
no one wanted to, if you
remember when they
shot everything up  The gas is the same as the
electricity prices and we
as the SPD faction really said to ourselves that we
have to put a cap on it
so that a certain degree of
security comes into the market and
of course that has already had a lot of
effect on the
families here  and people but also the
companies first go through the wuppa and
then my first project was
that I negotiated completely on my own to
get the free trade agreement with Canada on the way to ratification,
so Zeta means it was once such a
huge demo, so it was the Greens  On the other hand,
the SPD had a very difficult time back then and
now it's a traffic light,
because of course you
also ask yourself the question if we don't
trade with Canada, with whom then and that
was 10 days more or less
locked up here in the office  and these are
things that are a bit
more than um but
in this case negotiating means negotiating with the traffic light colleagues
or negotiating with Canada
nope nope nope nope so
that's what the EU does um we
negotiated with the traffic light colleagues like  We
can agree to this because
trade agreements usually have to
go through the national parliaments again and that wasn't easy in
the constellation between green, yellow and
SPD and there were three of us sitting here at
my table with our traffic light colleagues
and then there was one  We found a way
and then we wrote down a trade agenda
and said okay, which
points are important to us, that we also
look at social and ecological sustainability, not just at
tariffs etc. PPA, so to say that the
two big negotiations Z and and
those exactly and then that came
Heating law I've
put that off for a bit because it was really
awful, it was all there
that could have gone wrong somehow
and now it's our turn for
startups,
the future financing law but also
what's really important right now, the
industrial electricity price, so how do we get
the industry in ours  Country if the
electricity prices here are simply much more expensive
than everywhere else and what do
you do there? We are committed to making sure that
our long-term goal is now, by the
way, I heard the episode with enerpark
was also very exciting, so
in the long term we want a lot of solar
and wind and hydrogen, i.e. green
energy, but we're not there yet and
until we get to the point where we're talking about
a bridge of 5 to 7 years,
we need a government-guaranteed
price that companies
can count on so that they can now say,
man  Don't go to America
and build the new plant there, but I
can still stay in Germany as a chemical industry or as a
steel industry
and don't have to leave everything now
and that's the
bridge electricity price, how many people are
now working here for you, that
's 9 10 people, yes al
Absolutely and I mean for many
MPs,
the activity, the role of employer and
I would say being in the public eye
and at least the
role of employer is something that I bring
a lot with me through my start-up phase, yes
and but there is a budget for that  these
z people that means you ca
n't spend €200,000 or how do
you imagine no, so we have
every MP has a personnel budget,
that's around €24,23,000 which is then used for the
MP team and
I have that  in Berlin employees but
also in tria and then because
I am deputy chairwoman
here in the SPD I also have
parliamentary group
employees and they are
paid by the parliamentary group so to speak and so it was
really important that I also had someone on
hand  I've been doing it for a
little longer than I have,
so like everywhere else, a team that complements each other in terms of
experience and perspective is better
than if everyone walks through the
store new and how did you
get that straight away? I mean it's
eight people  They are deputy
faction members, there is a full member of the
parliamentary group but why did the D
do this directly? Yes, that is
actually something that has never existed before
because you actually start off in
some committee where you
maybe don't want to be
become a spokesman for a topic and there
are the deputy
chairmen and in our group
what I said at the beginning, more than
half of them are new, there has never been such
a blatant change so a lot of new
people. Secondly, some of them also have
responsibility now  changed into government,
for example my predecessor Sören
bartoll, who became State Secretary in the Ministry of Construction,
so many people
then moved from the parliamentary
group into the government and
then Rolf mützenig and our
parliamentary group leader said, man,
maybe we'll give a
new person the chance now  because the
topic of economics was free and we
now have an entrepreneur in our
ranks and we can now
try out taking on responsibility directly in the first
electoral term,
so that I now
have my jfix with Robert Habbeck and no longer
with my co-founder Mengting, who is really
hot  You'll see Robert only
once a month or in the
week of the session, so the
Bundestag usually meets for a week
and then the next week is the
so-called constituency week, so we
also live in two cities and I
always commute between Berlin and
Trier and when  When the week of the meeting is, there is
usually a regular meeting with
Economics Minister Robert Habbeck. Yes, yes,
that's interesting, yes, that
's something different, but
now the prospect for you is to do
it again in the next legislative period
and then, um, at some point, so
to speak  in order to get into office, so
to speak, who
are still closer to the government, maybe it
's not all up to you, but
a lot has to fit in,
so that a department then
becomes something free, which also gives you a
lot of skills  Of course,
if I can take responsibility,
it's also exciting
to see the other side of the table, but I
also feel very comfortable in what would be the most
viable position for you now, so
State Secretary, Minister, yes,
you can always do something like that  Let's imagine well, so
seeing the Ministry of Economic Affairs from the inside would certainly not be
entirely uninteresting, but of course you would have to
somehow get into the hands of the SPD, and
I can of course
not take Robert away from him now, but that's
why you can see that it's very, very,
very open  until you actually get
these ministries to be
divided between the partners and
of course you have to do the right
things and then there are a
lot of competent people in the SPD and
then someone has to say
Verena Huberts
Let's now start the race so
everything is relaxed and we continue to do good
work and then let's
see how close your relationship is with the SPD Chancellor, very close with Olaf Scholz, so every
Tuesday there is our parliamentary group meeting and
the Chancellor is there, so to speak  with
vort but of course we also have
various other topics with each other
that are then discussed with him but
also in the Chancellery we have with Jörg
Cookis who is also known as the festival
former gold sexber who now say there in the
uh yes economic or netim not at all
chancellor new earlier  was
the Ministry of Economic Affairs, he was in the
Ministry of Finance Olaf Scholz and
Wolfgang Schmidt and of course these are
the things that you talk to first hand
because the Chancellor doesn't take care
of everything personally but he also has to
watch what's going on around the world
but still they  Things in the
country are also regulated, but these are the ones
I
always see in my jfix, so to speak. Cookies in this
place. Yes, there are a lot of them, the
thesis that there
are no longer the right people in politics, but rather
entrepreneurs  It's all
a bit like professional politicians. If in
doubt, they become lawyers
who have been preparing for this all their lives
and that's why everything has
fallen into place, but if you
walk around here now you've just noticed that there are
even some Wu
graduates not only your your your your
your employees but  Also in
other parties there are
certainly more entrepreneurs and
than you would think, yes and I also think it's a
good thing that politics is becoming more diverse so
that we have different professional groups in
terms of age so we are also
we have 50 MPs under 35 so also
younger than  We have always
become and that reflects
society even more, but clearly
if you look at the Bundestag there
are still a lot of lawyers and
a lot of teachers here, okay and
you can see that in the appointment who
has what kind of background
You definitely notice when
someone from business is sitting across from you,
when someone from the business world is also
saying, man, if we now
make such and such a law then it will also have
such and such an effect and I can
also report that from my own experience,
I mean we  We don't have to have
experienced everything on our own in order to be able to
form an opinion. There are
many interest groups for that and you can
also visit companies, but I
think that it does something to you
if you're actually on the other
side then also with the rules and
Laws were allowed to come up with, it is
now a challenge for you
to have an economics minister who does
not come from an entrepreneurial background
but who, I think, has
an artistic,
literary background anyway and
there are also anecdotes or
moments in recent years
where  Robert Habbeck was accused
in interviews of being too far
away from real
business life. You can tell that, so we
actually
dealt with these bankruptcies
and of course you already know what
it's like to have to pay the bills at the end of the month
the salaries and the
sales and if you've already calculated five times
when you're actually going to
file for bankruptcy, it's of course
different than saying let it go
in the winter somehow, maybe um turn
off the light somehow and see
what happens next  In this
specific case, yes, but I think Robert
Habbeck does one thing really well:
he learns incredibly quickly and he can
communicate like no other and
this I mean dissatisfaction with politics
often comes from the fact that you
no longer understand what is being said
This authentic and honest
and calm manner is
also very good for this Berlin business
and do you think that
somehow you couldn't have
had more influence if you had
gone the classic route and now you're a
successful founder of either the next
company or you go to it  The Venter
capital fund then invests in
the next exciting companies and
tries to influence it, so if
you grow it like that, you think politics
is the stronger instrument, yes,
where you have influence on it, in
any case, because the laws  we
do affect the whole country,
the economy, the people and here
are the big boards that are
being drilled if you are now in the VC,
so in some fund that then
invests in something, of course
you can build the next unicorn somehow
and you can do great things there too
effect but here it's just
a bit bigger but and
I think that's the difference in
politics, which is why many managers
who are in politics become disillusioned very quickly
because here it's
not like I say that's how we do it,
but here  Are you part of
a huge democratic process, which is
good, but first I have to
convince the people in my group, then
I have to convince the people in the traffic lights,
then I also have to
make sure that we can finance it and
afford it and this one  The path
is just very very very very very
long but what in the end why is
it obviously a much bigger box
than what you
can achieve in business I'm sure it
's also public that's why I'm
now asking you very directly what you
deserve  you actually in your role oh, yes,
you can do that, it's also very
important that we are transparent there is a
parliamentary law that
regulates it
We also
pay taxes then we have to get
health insurance then we all donate
something at least in the SPD
to the SPD so at
some point you have a little something like four
net which is of course a good salary
in the sense of what an
average person earns  Human in Germany
but compared to if you say
now I'll choose the one where I maximize my salary,
that wouldn't be the choice
here, so you have to say quite openly if
you were to go to a VCF now, I
guess with your background it's
too likely  Since the base salary starts with 160,000 €
gross, I have no idea
what it is, but it could definitely be
more anyway, so then I also get
an extra bonus, so to speak, salary from the
group through the deputy role and we also get it
a flat rate where we
can rent a second apartment
and also an office in the constituency so that
's all
totally sufficient we have a
transport service which is also totally reasonable and
pension entitlements which are quite good no
exactly that too exactly yes so that's how it is
Not included in the
rentanspr Exactly that's exactly what you get even
after 4 years or I think
even if you leave earlier
exactly and the
transport service has its own driver not its
own driver that's what they have in the
ministries we have a
Bundestag transport service you can do that
here  You often need it to order for work appointments,
so you
already notice the rhythm here, it
really goes from A to B to C and it
helps that you're sitting in the car
and not in the S-Bahn so that you can
also hear phone calls  you can send emails,
etc. but they really stand in front of
you in a suit and hold the door open for you and
it's a danger, so
now I'm not the type that
I'm not feeling
great about, but that's it  There is a
risk that this will also
make people take off. You are driven
because it's a bit like, well, you
're suddenly important, at least
but I always have to say that, it's the
office and not the person, so I'm
not invited because I'm Verena
Huberts, I'm invited because
I'm a member of the Bundestag and
deputy chairwoman and I
also have to differentiate because if you're
thrown out, it's very
easy for you not to be invited
and then you can't
somehow fall into depression,
you have others like that  Friends from the
start-up scene who are also
involved, I think you know it
somehow, I think there are a few in the CDU,
so
I somehow noticed this with
Johannes Reck from get you
guide who I think is relatively close to the
CDU  It's
clear then there's Vena Poster I
think he FDP really knows what I mean she
's not in any party should make a
decision I've said many times now
we also need people like you
in the SPD Finn Hensel somehow who
was already CDU exactly city group so
There are many
other people in cannabis companies, so I experience a lot of people
who say you have to do it, but often
you don't dare to
stand up for a party, but the others that
we do all do on the side, they
all don't do any deputation, but they all
need that  We don't
just come when you say now
I want to be a member of parliament because that
doesn't work anyway, but what are
you giving for the party? Well, I
recently had a successful
founder who said, huh, I would have
wanted membership 10 years ago  Then it would be more
authentic if I tried that
and that's exactly what you don't want. You want
people to
join parties because of the conviction in order to
participate and not in order to
maybe offer themselves for this or that
position at some point, but that's what it means
how many hours a month or
so can you seriously help out
in your msassociation or something like that, well you can
even if you somehow
have an hour or two a week or
three hours a month, it's just a matter of
seeing what you could do  Because you're
moving, so if you
live in Hamburg and have no idea and you're
with the SPD and you're an
entrepreneur then you can say
okay Wisten in the House of Representatives for the
topic of economics, I'll meet the person
for coffee then I could  You can
ask where you are, where can you
use input? I could
try to network something for you somehow.
I could
write something down. I could also
go on the podium for you, but if
you do a flyer campaign I
might still be there  also there or
I could support him being
able to print the flyers, so um there are
a lot of things that you
can do without me having to go to the local meeting
once a month every Tuesday at 6 p.m.
There
were even times in the  I also know one of the SPDs
a little personally, an
entrepreneur from Ladenzeile, yes, me,
who came into office out of nowhere
and said I even wanted
to become a party member. That's exactly what I thought was
very brave and cool back then, but out of
nowhere is usually a
little bit  difficult, I think it was
also in the place or exactly yes,
but I mean from nowhere in the sense
of the party conference I had to
know it somehow, although
the members also made the decision, but
you also needed a few
local associations first  who supported one
and then of course that doesn't help
if you know a lot of people in the economic forum,
Hal has to know the locals,
so you have to
go to the district party conference here in Berlin, yes,
it's highly complex and it's an
inner-party democracy and what have
you  what have you done for your region
so far for or in yes both so what
about the change did you just
tell me more like national ung
exactly what was going on at the local e what you
have now initiated yes,
interestingly enough, I also have that now
I wrote a letter at the same time that I was
writing it down because I formulated
the exact question: What's in it for you that I
'm here now?
So of course, in addition to all the
galactic topics that we discuss here in the
traffic light, we
also have funding programs  and then you can stand up
for it as a member of parliament,
for example, I've now managed to
get a new bicycle garage at Porta Nikra, which
also has an electric charging station where you
can lock up your stuff. Great, then
the church hall in Tria Süd is being renovated. Then
I have  for a swimming pool in
Hermeskall, of course, these are
the funding projects that
people notice specifically on site because
the thing is in
need of renovation and now it's being
remade somehow
bullish in the next few years, there are
also very different voices, especially
now, the energy policy
challenge in general, the
energy industry challenge in particular,
um the W now the
auto industry in China has all these
issues that many people around me
also say that it's all very difficult and
The best years are behind us,
I think the best is still to come, but we
have to make an effort to make it happen. What makes
them so optimistic
because when you are out and about here in the
country you can really see what is
being achieved by both startups
and e.g  We were at Sunfire in Tresden, they
build electrolyzers, these are the things
you need for hydrogen to be
mega successful, um, and I mean,
this
whole change from gas to hydrogen
and these things is just now happening, so I think we
've missed a lot too  What we shouldn't have
missed is the fact that
a Tesla leaves us standing there so blatantly
and it feels like all
the car manufacturers are looking stupid.
That's bitter, but what we do is a
we can manage
to move forward again VW has now
announced an E  -Wanting
to produce a car for 25, but if it's
not bought in China or if
it's too small in China,
I think it's also dangerous for VW, of course,
the economy is a globalized one,
it's all interconnected and that's
why we have to look at how we're
packing  now not all
The inventors and
thinkers actually
have great prerequisites to really master this whole climate tech area.
Point one point
two, I think Germany can
always do more in the crisis than we can perhaps
even imagine in our comfortable
existence. Look
what we're doing with them now  LNG terminals have been
achieved, we all thought we were
going to bang left and
right here because suddenly Russia
stopped supplying the gas and we
did it but we also have to
do it and that's the third and
last point
understand, it's 1115 a.m. That's
why Chancellor Olaf Scholz
proposed the Germany Pact because we've
been talking about reducing bureaucracy for 1000 years and
actually
getting it done so that you
can re-register online and it actually
works and in this
Germany the
planning acceleration doesn't just focus on the
Rolling out renewables but also
on a few other things and
everyone has to work together a little bit
and then you're back
to a complex country with 16
federal states and that's why we need
this pact a from an economic perspective,
which industries do you see as the
German industries of the future?  You
look at the next 15 15 years, so
I think it's very good that we're pursuing an active
economic policy because if you
look at what we were missing right
now, for example.  Semiconductors are such a
huge thing that we have now
settled here and are now
at the forefront with these microchips,
but I think the big things are
really climate tech, i.e.
everything from electrolysers to how do
we become efficient  in the
whole topic of batteries, i.e. controlling smart crits
with each other, etc. then
I think also in the area of ​​computers, i.e.
quantum computing. I mean, look at
Karlsruhe Munich and the surrounding area, so that's where
we actually have the brains and the
tackies and then you have to
ask yourself how we get it  that on the
street and there's e.g. Sprint the
agency for jump innovation really
cool guy
rapaeluna already experienced it a few times yes yes so
then get the malusz and
say people we
really have to get out of science and
into innovation and commercialization
So there's a lot going on and Celones is
showing what can be done. I mean they
're already worth over 10 billion
with this data mining process
and we need the next SAPs and I
think they can be
created very well in Germany but
they're really visible  not yet zelonus yes
but otherwise there are still
a few smaller ones but at
the level towards 10
billion plus there isn't that much now that's
why we have to
change the framework conditions e.g. so that we
also have more later stage capital here
so we have at  the
financing rounds if you
need 200 or 300 million then
the staatsfor from Singapore comes
around the corner like at beontech,
our answer cannot be not being
able to participate and that's why we need
growth capital at the back but also
better conditions for
employee capital participation the topic of
esop  and these are the things that we are now
tackling with a startup strategy that has
never existed in this country. There is
also less regulation in this country.
Of course, it is clear that in
Germany everything has a standard for everything, there are
thousands of laws for everything
A bit of protection from
all the Chinese suppliers
and so you probably also follow
e-commerce somehow the skiins and
temus and so deliver in here relatively
unrestrictedly at low prices and so
here you have to make life difficult for the German dealers and German
e-commerce startups,
you have to be clear  Think about how
we deal with this, not only with
competition from China but also what is
meant by the term carbon leakage, i.e. when we say we
now have great climate protection laws and
no one in Germany produces
green steel anymore, but they produce
Krauenstahl in China and import it
We now have to protect ourselves, for example. There will
soon be CO2 border tariffs,
but I don't think we
can protect ourselves from everything now, the world
is a free
competition, and that's a good thing, but we have to
set the rules that not everyone
follows  he can do whatever he wants
and how he wants, which is why these
trade agreements now clarify a few
more things with each other than
just customs duties.
In the end, you don't actually start such a big digital film
as your own, so an
Apple or in Google or  Amazon
actually depends on their role and the
rules they set for
all the people who use them.
A lot of them do it, almost like they start,
so I mean they define very
strongly what we do, how we do it,
so there are  Rules are now set in
companies, but a start
makes a little more
because you don't become a citizen
with a Facebook login, so that's
of course worth considering that a
Facebook Amazon Google what amount of
data they have and what they do with it,
of course  can also monetize and
I think we need to make everyone aware of this next year when there
are European elections.
I think Europe has to
be careful about what we do in terms of regulation so that they don't
just
collect the data, monetize it,
resell it and do it  what they
want, but that there is also more
competition possible again, so that
Facebook was allowed to buy a WhatsApp,
so of course that's next to
Instagram, so that's really a
universe that was built there where you, there
are almost no people  Even
if you're not on Facebook, where you do
n't have contact points with Facebook in any way
or Meta as it's called,
the EU has to
be much stronger because you inherit so much
lobbying, so a lot of people come to you
and try to promote their concerns
constantly and constantly that is also
the big challenge in politics to
think about where do I go for an
appointment what do I look at what am
I taking and where so how do I limit myself
so saying no is
actually the greatest art now but you  I
told you in advance that all the big
DAX bosses are coming and are sitting down at
the table where I can now sit
and then we're not from
VW, Blackrock, you have them all here in the
office, that
's actually a different role now  Comparison
to the founder because if you now
see my role in the SPD parliamentary group, I am
now, so to speak, the highest-ranking
economic politician. Then I
meet with my spokesman Bern Festfall and that is of course a
very relevant
conversation channel for the companies because I
can now incorporate things into both
Legislation but even if we don't
agree with it, every law here doesn't
go through this parliament and
is of course correspondingly effective.
Yes, the position that
was held there. For me it's important not to
say that I'm just listening to the VW now,
but that I want to  Also
talk to the Child Protection Association because
as a member of parliament you are responsible
for a variety of topics, so in the
constituency you are a generalist, here
you are a specialist in Berlin and then you
also have to find a good balance with whom do
you talk to who do you talk to who do you
talk to  You don't either, but
American politics, American
entrepreneurs, entrepreneurs who
somehow represent companies, you don't have them
here. Reg, but I'm now
also meeting him, I know it's public,
but it'll be the Microsoft CEO
and so on, so those are the
conversations when they do  They're
also inviting you to Berlin and that's of course
a great opportunity if you think about the fact
that back then Tim Cuck had
n't announced his return yet. He'd like to be invited back. That would close
the circle, yes, that would be
nice, but of course Apple and so on, they
're all on the move too  Each
company is actually on its own
and then organized into associations,
for example BITCOM is
the association for the digital companies,
then you have the VCI for the
chemical industry, the BDI for the
health industry, self-critical, not just like that and
in the end so is the
energy  I think that means saying to a satella like that,
sorry we
do, so of course you want to
get into the controversy, but I'm
only when I say we can't do that,
that's not the case yet. We'll probably have to then
By that I
mean a lot of the jurisprudence is
also at the European level but
of course I'm not here
to agree with them but also to say,
man, have you ever
looked at this, we have it, which
might also help you
but also broaden your perspectives  Because
if you say politics is always about
finding compromises in
different situations and
someone can't always get their 100%
demand then it would
n't work
Sitting with you
when he I don't think he does
political discussions and to be honest
with his ex and Twitter I do
n't know if I would want to have a
very confrontational exchange with him
so you're not a fan of that
so with Twitter I think he does that
Really really broken right now and he
somehow kicked out half of the
fake news team or transparency
campaigning team yesterday, so
I'm watching this with a lot of
concern about what's actually happening on such a cool channel - there
are
still such German personalities,
man  You have an eye on them,
you try to support them in some way, they
do something good, so special, so
who could be the next German
entrepreneur or entrepreneur?
Verena is mentioned again and again,
but without a company, so to speak,
as an individual, there are no others  Where do you
say human beings do you develop people or
or look, do you support companies
or something like that,
so I
'm now a bit out of the loop
when it comes to new start-ups,
but one person you
should definitely get to know is Karoline
Weimann from joint politics, she's
exactly there  Interface
between politics and startups are,
so to speak, e.g. hanno Renner has also
invested there exactly and they say we
want to push talent for politics
and
new ideas take new paths and they are taking
the vc approach for talent in
politics, so to speak, you've got it
right in the media  what got so I mean me
all the time actually yes yes yes so if
you Google you
I can't find the shitstorm I haven't
found the shitstorm oh so not the shitstorm
but if you look at the comments or the
messages you get
so if you  somehow when I'm
sitting with Markus Land it says
underneath what kind of idea they had, they
should study and then
I'm happy when I can write underneath it,
thank you, I have, so often, yes, now
and then, but my team
always tries  Isolating it a bit
because it doesn't
necessarily always make you happy when you see all
the hateful comments under posts and
videos, how important are
traditional media
because I notice when you
sit on a talk show like that, it's
just not up to par  a YouTube video or
with a yes with a TV
is still being watched,
newspapers are still being read, so if
you are now in the Spiegel in the FAZ or
Trier Volksfreund then that has
a different relevance than
if you just read something on your channel
write because of course my
channel doesn't have all the consequences
that a mirror subscription has, but if
you look at the USA, it's a
bit like the future that it's
actually almost not like that anymore, because win
politicians and most media
are against it and or against it  I also write openly against it, but
it doesn't matter that much. There's
actually a tendency here too. I
mean, the FD isn't that strong because
it always has such great articles in the
newspapers and of course they mobilize
all the trolls very digitally and of
course they do that too  E.g.
also politics for the social media
by talking in the Bundestag,
not for the plenary session, the people who
sit there talk so that it
works particularly well on TikTok
and then they hold up a sign like that,
so they are also offended
against rules because you're not actually allowed to
do that and being against it is
always easier than being in favor of things
and confrontation is always
more interesting than being in favor of an idea,
but it's really the
case that extreme parties in particular
often have better social media
I've often
observed that when it comes to strategy, they then
discover very quickly what works,
create memes about what you just meant
or, of course, they also have more extreme
positions that are a bit
favored, but
you have to say that they are also very smart
Unfortunately, yes, you can copy something,
maybe
even certainly there is in the willly
Brandhaus in the group but also in
my team, we are constantly looking
from left to right at kitchen
stories, for example, back then we did
n't analyze the best cooking apps,
but we have  looked at how does abnb do
a great onboarding and
we also look at who communicates and on
which channel not only
politicians and my aim is to
constantly develop myself further but of
course you are just one person and
not a whole ship but I bring  Of
course, I'm also on the ship that's
called the SPD and the SPD faction. There are
politicians like that, maybe or
politicians from other countries who inspire you so much,
so in the USA I could
imagine a lot of people watching what
AOC is doing. Then somehow the
boss is there  in New Zealand who also
worked very strongly in the media, then in
Finland there was a lady who, I think, is
no longer in office in Sant
Marin, but if you look at something like that,
you are also a bit like you
used to be, a bit so natural about it
Beyond the plate and what others are doing, that's part of it
and you can
also get inspiration from it, for example
the SPD also does it and says, man, take a look
at the Labor newsletter in the
UK,
you can also
learn a little bit from that  I
also subscribed to other party newsletters,
of course, macron in France,
which was a
huge success story in the beginning, but also
especially in Austria, we at the
SPÖ, the Social Democrats, have seen the
change of Andreas Babler, who is also
now coming through with a whole new momentum
Corner comes, by the way, there is also
prinkert, so the SPD election campaign is exactly what
the
Austrian colleagues are doing now and you can see
right there, so when
motivation and momentum
come together, then something really works,
okay, there are also people, so you have a
PR agency  who represents you, no, so
we really do everything
in-house, as they say, and my
office manager Stefan, who is, so to speak, also
in terms of his professional profile, he was previously at
the financial turnaround, so there was also
something in between politics and
campaigning and we think  We
actually communicate with each other here, but
and that's cool too, I have a
circle of friends
around me who all have something to do
with politics or
communication professionally in some way and we have one like that every now
and then
Wine group where we
sit down here and especially
this view from the outside because you know that,
even if you're chatting all the time
you have to
get a perspective from the outside
and that also helps a lot. Your current circle of
friends is then  now half
politics half daily startup or or
half old friends yes in
politics and unfortunately that's a
bit of a shame
you have to so I'm actually a
person who trusts you I
'm open I actually always believe in
the good but here in Berlin  Is it the case
that SMS are screenshotted
and forwarded, so you have to
look very carefully where do you open the
door a little further
and who can you really
trust now and that's uh there's
definitely so it's not all of them
Not everything is a hot basin, but it
's definitely something to be treated with more caution, which is
why I'm very
grateful that I
have a circle of friends in Berlin who
are also outside of this turning point
because there are a lot of people who
get very involved here very quickly  and only a
parliamentary evening, so to speak,
or here and there and so on. That's why
my circle of friends is actually still
startup-like, but also a
bit of a political cosmos from the
spd era and then of course in tria you
're a school friend, a student friend, a family,
you're on Whatsapp, of course, so that means
I also have your OMR newsletter every
Friday I get the K I'm always horny
I'm very titic it's good
yes tell me I'm on WhatsApp I've still had
my number since I was 13
I think at some point I'll have to change it if you're now then
maybe you
don't expect it again  Can you continue, what do you want
to do then
no plan B then I think I
would first of all I actually wanted to go
to kitchen stories back then for a few months
I didn't do any traveling then
I would do that then I would
think about it then I would
think about it  let's see but
talk to people or so that people
talk to everyone now
everyone knows that I'm sitting pretty well in the
saddle here and having fun here and
would like to continue that so
there's no real one today in the
so  here for me now not no
but fantasy more concrete absit V travels
that the person might then go into
the toilet scene or into the Pesszene or
um I don't know into which I don't know to
start something new again or so I think
I couldn't find a way at the moment
imagine because it's
hard for me to imagine putting so much
energy into one topic over such a long period of time,
so I realize
what I really enjoy here is
the diversity of topics, so you
somehow have such a potpory of
things on the table  and that's really
exciting and that's why I think who
capital would be something because you
also see different things and
can also help people,
perhaps
with a network with experience in one place or another, but I do
n't know we have to  Look, but
it's the case that often
when you've been in politics for a certain amount of time,
you also
get cool job offers then in
business that you suddenly let's say
like that, there were also examples of being a
railway board member or something correct
You can also imagine railway board member Verena Huber,
oh if you can
still get Deutsche Bahn to FL, Wissing will have to
take care of it, but our
traffic is clear, but I
always think that's so hypothetical, what are
you doing after Ohmer, I'll retire oh until Z
Yes, you see, maybe I do
too. I'm retiring,
I don't have to, so I have to give myself a
bit of choice with my
employees. Employees maybe but
not in the same way, always a lot of
crystal ball and I think
you can't live life like that  right, life is
somehow lived forwards and
understood backwards and somehow it has
always been so natural until now I have ideas about
what you can do but I have yes, I am
here now and I am an ambassador who is
abroad, you will also be able to do it well, I
think you would  So I think
I would also be well represented by you
if anyone could, but
that's very complex, you
also have to have a law degree unless you've been in
government for a long time, so they
all went through this diplomatic school
and here
he is now Kraf Lamstdorf  to Russia but
I think he was also before, he's not
Mrs. Merkel's former spokesman,
but because he's proven himself so diplomatically
over so many years, you
basically get a YES to him, but that's the case
with you even if you have this job  Now
here we sort of clarify things, then
we can
think about it again, all right, um
yes, we now have something like that, I hope
we don't have any
strong SPD coloring in it,
but we already have a podcast, go
with other parties, so
everything should fit  But there are
n't that many SPDs in startups,
so there are startup barometers,
most of them are green or FDP. No, yes, it's a shame.
I'm still promoting more entrepreneurship
in the SPD because I think that's what happens
after a big rise through founding a company  It
actually fits really well with the SPD because it
doesn't count your parents' house, it
doesn't count your school qualifications, it's
somehow your own idea, passion
and vision that counts and that's
actually a lot of people who can
Yes, the SPD is also going green, so we're
looking for good people in any capacity
and that's why we want to get involved and
support it. That would be something, so
thank you for this non-partisan, it used to be
said that at the time it was
always okay,
we would also like to be independent, but still  F I'm
obviously very interesting in a way and
very competently how you did it, you notice
a little bit that you've
already got this role, so I'll
think about it now, but maybe it's
not so bad if you
do a little bit of what's
expected of you  Well, in any case,
thank you very much for taking the time to see us
again and let's see, we'd be
happy to accompany you where you
won't be able to hear again in the next week or
so
]